[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 23 décembre bienvenue dans
ce journal de la rédaction de tv 78
c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
en quelques minutes à la une ce soir les
vacances de noël qui ont débuté avant de
réveillonner et d'ouvrir les cadeaux il
fallait s'occuper aujourd'hui avec des
activités aux clayes-sous-bois la
piscine intercommunale qui est ouverte
quasiment pendant toutes les congés
propose aussi des stages de natation
pour les enfants le reportage de michael
et demi d'euros à deux jours de noël ces
enfants décidé d'enfiler un bonnet de
bain pendant leurs vacances il participe
ce lundi 23 décembre un stage de
natation organisé à la piscine salvador
allende les clayes-sous-bois le but
apprendre en s'amusant sous l'oeil d'un
maître nageur objectif ça va être
sécuritaire principalement et que du
coup ça va aller avec de la technique
pour pouvoir les faire progresser plus
facilement et qui sache voilà à faire un
maximum de distance en tout cas avec un
minimum d'efforts et à un peu plus de
technique que ce qu'ils ont au début
le rendez vous est proposé à partir de 5
ans jusqu'à 12 ans pour les enfants de
saint quentin en yvelines où des saisons
virements via des enfants qu'on a on
scolaire par exemple et qui viennent
pour avoir dû plus y en a qui sont même
en club et qui viennent aussi parce que
c'est une activité aussi qui les
occupent et qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils
aiment ça aussi mais c'est aussi tout
simplement des gens autour qui veulent
qu'ils veulent que leurs enfants
progressent au total quatre enfants
participent aujourd'hui à cette séance
qui peut durer de 45 minutes à une heure
comment nager sur les deux sur le ventre
avec la sava ses incessants avec la
frite oui sur l'afrique ça va le tarif
pour la semaine est compris entre 56 et
60 8 euros pour quatre séances si vous
avez manqué cette session de noël la
structure organisera un nouveau stage
sur des prochaines vacances
le reste de l'actualité en bref une
action en justice d'abord deux à sept
associations environnementales elle
porte plainte contre x avec constitution
de partie civile pour pollution des eaux
le but de l'ouverture d'une instruction
judiciaire suite à la rupture du
pipeline d'ile-de-france de total
souvenez vous en février dernier une
fuite s'était produite dans un champ au
niveau d'eau tout y est de boissy sans
avoir résultat un million de litres de
pétrole qui s'étaient déversés est les
associations craignent une pollution
considérable une première plainte avait
été déposée auprès du procureur de la
république de versailles sans succès le
pipeline qui relie la raffinerie de
grandpuits en seine-et-marne et le dépôt
pétrolier du havre était remise en
service depuis juillet vingt-cinq mille
véhicules empruntent chaque jour cet axe
très encombré c'est le pont de la
villedieu qui relie l encours à la
verrière pourrait être doublé à l'instar
du pont schuller
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaiterait
passer l'édifice en deux fois deux voies
dans le cadre de son plan anti bush ont
une étude sera effectué à ce sujet à
l'agglomération a identifié le pont de
la ville dieu comme l'un des points
bloquants sur la circulation du
territoire l étude chiffrée à 1 million
et demi d'euros sera cofinancé par la
collectivité est mais aussi la région
ile de france et le département des
yvelines
le président du département justement
pierre bédier continue ses rencontres du
territoire un cycle de visites lancé en
octobre pour témoigner sur place de
l'action du conseil départemental la
semaine dernière déplacement sur le
thème et de la mobilité du développement
économique à saint nom la bretèche
feucherolles ou encore crêpière pierre
bédier a été accueilli par les deux
gourmands producteur de biscuits et de
miel installé à la ferme neuve sur place
cette entreprise et 35 emplois avec
quelques ajustements nécessaires les
propos recueillis par manon varaldo ce
développement il a besoin d'être aidé et
soutenu et aujourd'hui on demande au
président du conseil général monsieur
bédié de nous aider à régler un problème
de logistique et de sécurité devant
notre ferme le long de cette
départementale
il est très difficile d'entrer sur notre
mieux voilà donc l'objet de la visite
c'était de présenter notre activité et
et de demander un soutien pour sécuriser
l'entrée de notre ferme
moi j'adore le contact avec les
personnes et comprendre les problèmes de
ces personnes et on comprend mieux en
dialoguant qu'en lisant une note
assis derrière son bureau moi j'adore
les entrepreneurs des entrepreneurs sse
et les créateurs de richesse c'est le le
sang neuf dans notre pays a besoin et
donc pouvoir échanger avec eux là j'ai
rencontré des jeunes des jeunes
entrepreneurs c'est rien du bonheur un
papa qui a transmis la fibre
entrepreneuriale à son fils qui a créé
sa propre entreprise dans un secteur
totalement différent c'est un grand
moment de richesse humaine et c'est
formidable
on referme ce journal en forêt lieu ô
combien important pour la biodiversité
lieu intéressant aussi pour se balader
écouter le chant des oiseaux pour
préserver cet espace le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
a initié un cycle de balade
le reportage de gwenaëlle saintilan
savoir reconnaître les champignons les
insectes reconnaître les traces du
passage d'un écureuil à la façon dont il
a grignoté une pomme de pain la forêt
c'est un écosystème fragile qui regorge
de richesses naturelles
il faut donc savoir la comprendre
l'observer pour pouvoir la respecter le
temps d'une balade solène boivin guide
au sein du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse a pu nous
faire découvrir les nombreuses espèces
protégées dont regorge le site
une balade de chaînes en être majestueux
bercé par le chant des oiseaux et le son
du vent dans les feuilles en tant que
guide de parcs je propose des visites
guidées sur différentes thématiques
ça peut être des thématiques qui
concernent le petit patrimoine
bien sûr l'environnement le
développement durable et ce sur le
territoire du parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse ce pnr
compte trois réserves naturelles et il y
en a une quatrième qui qui est en cours
de création qui concerne les étangs de
hollande et
et les rigoles également il ya également
le petit moulin des vaux de cernay qui
est un site assez remarquable il est
dans un environnement qui est très riche
avec plus de 217 espèces de plantes à
fleurs
alors je propose également des balades
pour un public familial qui s'appelle
les petits curieux ars et dans
différents endroits du pnr il ya
différentes espèces alice un peu comme
le vinaigre
des balades sont organisées pour tous
les publics scolaires ou adultes en
groupes ou individuels
le pnr les propose tout au long de
l'année pour faire découvrir la faune et
la flore de ces espaces
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité retour de l'information
locale demain même heure belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]